how many conversations did you guys have
up until the point where it's like we're
not doing this yeah so I mean and not to
rehash like all that stuff because I
think people now kind of know like you
make your decision and I love Jordan
Peterson like Andrew like I'm still
friends with a lot of people over there
um the issue there was there was never
look the issue I always had was and I
said take me off the table because it
wasn't going to be a fit the issue was
with other people the primary issue you
never heard me talk about money and I
was a business guy that's probably like
nails on a chalkboard but it's uh you
know you can't penalize people you can't
put on 110 penalties on behalf of big
Tech literally 110 penalties
um but primarily if you have other kids
who are coming up like you can't punish
conservative content creators on behalf
of big Tech saying not only do you have
to be there you have to be monetized
which you know on YouTube right that's a
very different set of guidelines is
basically don't say anything offensive
ever all I can say is is uh there was
never anything that we went over that
involved that being eliminated
[Music]
thank you